allerdings ist die frage ob er wohl auch
zeit hat nach waghäusel zu schauen
dort gibt es nämlich deutschlands
erfolgreichste foodbloggerin die kommt
ja aus baden württemberg aus dem
badischen waghäusel
foodbloggerin die lady kocht und backt
teils gemeinsam mit töchterchen das
ganze daheim in der küche filmt sich
selbst dabei und hunderttausende schauen
im internet zu wir jetzt auch und günter
preckel hat sie sogar besucht
ben saly kamera und scheinwerfer an
macht wird ihre küche zum filmstudio
klappe für ein neues video
die zutaten say is back und koch videos
gehört zu den absoluten rennern bei
youtube die 26-jährige hat bereits 180
internet videos produziert töchterchen
samira ist fast immer dabei und
unterstützt ihre mama dankeschön eine
leckere quark füllung und da kommt jetzt
noch die missbildung mit drauf dass ich
auch - füllung durch in meinem lust auf
video bereits verwendet habe die idee zu
ihren videos hat sie sich aus den usa
geholt
dort gibt es das schon länger dann habe
ich gedacht kommen in deutschland gibt
es noch nicht haben nur bisher einige
beauty blockerinnen oder blogger mal
rezepte versucht und da habe ich gedacht
mit dem hintergrundwissen aus der
hauswirtschaft kann ich das einfach
alles verbinden und kann einfach mal
auch so ein rezept online stellen
celle ist keine gelernte bäckerin sie
hat hauswirtschaft deutsch und englisch
studiert und ihr referendariat zur
grundschullehrerin erfolgreich
absolviert irgendwann will sie ins
lehramt einsteigen
doch derzeit dreht sich bei ihr alles um
ihre torten welt und dabei hat sie
besondere ansprüche
ich will einfach so wie im unterricht
eben auch die leute hätten bisschen
weiterbilden
bei mir geht es nicht nur um die rezepte
sondern ich sage auch wo man die
lebensmittel her bekommt was saisonal
oder regional ist bis ein video sende
fertig ist muss elli die aufgenommenen
szenen sichten und schneiden
das ist für sie die größte
herausforderung zwei videos produziert
sie pro woche und sie hat schon über
100.000 abonnenten damit lässt sich geld
verdienen natürlich jetzt mal stolz
darauf was ich geleistet habe vor allem
auch weiter kein katar bin und ich habe
mir das alles irgendwie selber aneignen
müssen dass videos schneiden das drehen
so fing vor zwei jahren alles an sally
backt einen lostopf
um ihre privatsphäre zu schützen will
sie ihren richtigen namen in der
öffentlichkeit nicht preisgeben
sallys torten welt wächst bald will sie
einen online shop eröffnen
dennoch bleibt sie bescheiden und
natürlich ich bin lehrerin ich bin
künstlerin mama ehefrau aber als da will
ich nicht backen ist seit ihrer kindheit
die große leidenschaft ihr youtube kanal
stylist orten welt ein erfolgsrezept das
rezept gibt es zum nachlesen ob solist
orten welt.de und ich freue mich schon
wieder das nächste mal bis bald